[Musik]
die meisten männer bestreiten schon mal
im puff gewesen zu sein obwohl
statistisch jeder vierte mann in meinem
alter schon für sex bezahlt haben soll
ich glaube es sind noch viel mehr sonst
wäre der mann neben mir im schwarzen
shirt niemals zu reich geworden
[Musik]
ingo heidbrink verdient sehr viel geld
damit dass viele männer sehr viel lust
haben und dass ein paar frauen für den
traum vom besseren leben ihren körper
verkaufen
[Musik]
ich wollte den mann kennenlernen der ein
leben führt dass man vor neid erblassen
könnte
[Musik]
wir treffen uns am flughafen in kloten
er kam standesgemäß im rolls royce ingo
heidbrink
seine geschäfte laufen so gut dass er
für den termin im tessin einen kleinen
jet mieten kann
in vielen ländern
heidbrink möchte in der nähe von lugano
ein bordell eröffnen seine freude an der
käuflichen liebe entdeckte er schon als
gymnasiast
damals sagte er einer jungen frau die
für ihn schwärmte er wolle nur frauen
die für ihn am schafften ein paar wochen
später kam sie mit einem bündel
banknoten wieder sie wurden ein paar
[Musik]
heidbrink wurde jurist er arbeitete als
gerichtsschreiber in schwyz und hatte
nebenbei stets freundinnen die sich
prostituierten
eines tages tauchte eine der damen im
gericht auf wurde handgreiflich und
beschimpfte ihn heidbrink machte schluss
als jurist und setzte voll auf 6
inzwischen besitzt der acht klubs ein
neunter soll bald dazukommen toni soll
im tessin geschäftsführer werden
schon heute ist ingo heidbrink der
erfolgreichste sechs unternehmer der
schweiz das gefühl etwas unehrenhaft es
zu tun hat er nicht
ja klar
wenn sie die fahrerfrage tun damit ihr
kampf
und
[Musik]
ich glaube sogar dass jetzt da das nicht
wie links religiöser glaube dass
es überraschte mich das hat bringt seine
katholische überzeugung mit einem
geschäft in einklang bringen kann in
welchem der ehebruch grundlage des
erfolges ist es sollte aber nicht die
letzte überraschende aussage sein
[Musik]
die privatisierung
er war nicht gewollt sagen was ich will
mich alle so gar nicht her aber müssen
sie vorher
das merkt gefühl dass mit präsident
sehen ist
jetzt kann ich sagen ja
das sind doch sind zwischenmenschliche
gefühle aber natürlich lebensgefühl im
eigentlichen sinn
[Musik]
im tessin wartete ein deutscher
geschäftsmann der seinen namen im
zusammenhang mit modellen lieber nicht
öffentlich machen wollte er hatte für
heidbrink nach geeigneten immobilien in
der sonnenstube der schweiz ausschau
gehalten
der mann führt uns zu einem
leerstehenden gebäude unweit von lugano
hier über die rampe sind
parkmöglichkeiten
also so blieb das im dings und dank und
darf
im großen aufenthaltsraum ja gut das
wird natürlich
nicht
wir fuhren weiter nach kassow ins
industriequartier
möglicherweise würde heidbrink hier den
begriff grenzverkehr schon bald eine
neue bedeutung geben
das abo nicht dass ich so was brauche
ich doch sagen
dort blieb er auf der iss
[Musik]
was spricht für das
ddp
wer da spricht was mit beruf stehen
sämtliche falsche vorstellung ist man
sich seit das roots music in die
romantische das ist eine falsche
vorstellungen in dustrie wo dann staut
es sich so schön wenn man nicht sagen
bis mediterran zu erstellen das ist
zweifellos so
muss für praktikabel danke
ich kannte ingo heidbrink noch kaum aber
mir schien er denkt sehr oft praktikabel
nach drei stunden flogen wir zurück in
die deutschschweiz auf dem rückflug
wollte ich nochmals auf seinen job zu
sprechen kommen nicht interessierte was
ihn von einem zuhälter unterscheidet
[Musik]
18 eigentliche zuhälter entweder setzt
es in anspruch ohne mein team hat mit
bald tourer oder nützt fürs lag vor der
frau
diese arbeit ist auch dem auch ich
werde mir wirtschaften damit wir müssen
[Musik]
ein paar tage später durften wir
heidbrink auf dem weg zur arbeit
begleiten unsere absicht war seine villa
wenigstens von außen zu filmen doch
kurzfristig hatte er den termin um eine
stunde vorverlegt es war noch
stockdunkel als wir ihn in schindellegi
trafen ich bin mir fast sicher dass er
das absichtlich gemacht hatte die fahrt
im rolls royce war dann aber sehr
angenehm
das globe in schwerzenbach wahrheit
brings erster klub und ist heute noch
seine goldgrube an guten tagen vergnügen
sich hier bis zu 200 männer und frauen
alle bezahlen 95 franken eintritt weit
bringt stellt nur die räumlichkeiten zur
verfügung
mit diesem geschäftsmodell macht er
allein im globe jeden monat eine halbe
million franken umsatz in kleineren
clubs ist es zwar weniger aber immer
noch genug als dass man heidbrink
bedauern müsste
eine kallas betrachte bin immer auf der
sonnenseite gestanden
aber ich hatte also
wäre deutlich machen dass mein körper
mit einem einschreiben welche software
soll das in anderen stadt ist auch
kleinste
ich durfte dabei sein und miterleben wie
heidbrink im team als boss funktioniert
von angst ist zumindest in diesem moment
wenig zu spüren eine halbe stunde lang
hörte er sich ruhig mit an was seine
engsten mitarbeiter im alltag so
beschäftigt dann eröffnete er ihnen die
wichtigsten änderungen
so kommt karin eksen es ist anders so
brauchte sie hat das ganz wunderbar
kommen hofer rechte spur derselbe mann
der im rolls royce zur arbeit fährt und
ins tessin den jet nimmt dabei
papiertüchern an sparpotenzial
express eine sid foto köster
[Gelächter]
ja und was in köln aber es ist ein
widerspruch wenn sie mit dem großen
rolls royce fahren durch drei täter
könnten liegt da wenig gesprochen für
unter kilometer und auf der anderen für
die klinik speicher
ist sie für klinik sei nicht tradition
von rolls royce show
an diesem vormittag lernte ich sabrina
kennen sich damit
quasi nackt am empfang auftauchte um den
eintritt zu bezahlen war ich völlig
überrumpelt es war halb elf und ich
versuchte ein interview mit ihr zu
machen
[Musik]
hatten sie schon lange her ja
man kann hier frei arbeiten
sagt dir einen eindruck von das was man
verfügt es einem selbst
dann kommen die geschäftsleitung sehr
gut klar
also das ist okay natürlich ist okay und
was macht ihnen spaß
dass der oberen der männer
wieviel erhoben sie denn so kotak ist
immer unterschiedlich
sinn ist es unverständlich dass ist
und wie machen sie das
haben sie einen tipp
jeder mann ist anders
ich fragte mich ob sabrina wirklich aus
freien stücken hier arbeitete oder
bobbys männer gab die sie dazu zwangen
risiko besteht dass
keine frau oder wo sie dann keine
berücksichtigt oder weiß ist und zwar
ziemlich genau wo die mitglieder wohnen
und die verhältnis kann immer noch die
erfahrung aus der persönlichen ehre
warum zum beispiel auch schon davor dass
frauen vorbereitet und dunks etwas
wohnung sollte dann strahlt das wort
[Musik]
heidbrink ist 47 jahre alt und vater von
drei töchtern
obwohl er sich sehr offen gibt hatte ich
ständig das gefühl dass er gerade mit
dieser zur schau gestellten offenheit
etwas kaschieren wollte hinter dem
imposanten auftritt und seinen muskeln
verband sich vielleicht mehr als ein
paar schweizer meistertitel im
bodybuilding
im film aus statt dass ich ein programm
pro woche
krafttraining
kraft anhänge betrieben hat zweite
strömung
brauchen sich muskeln an alter nachbar
die muskeln zusammen
[Musik]
heidbrink ist einer der seltenen figuren
im sexgewerbe die das tageslicht der
öffentlichkeit nicht scheuen er hatte
aber unumwunden zugegeben dass er nur
deshalb jahr zur reportage sage weil sie
für ihn gute werbung bedeutet
[Musik]
im mittelpunkt stehe und an der
königlichen
ich habe mir meine mama
journalisten spaß weil ich begebe mich
stark in eine gefahrensituation
wieso
eigentlich
journalisten
stehen sie eigentlich
eigentlich vor allem
viel geld verdienen
aber
interessant
in einer seiner teuren karossen fuhren
wir anschließend dahin wo ingo heidbrink
seine jugend verbracht hatte nach
pfäffikon am oberen zürichsee
sein vater starb bevor er sehen konnte
womit sein sohn erfolgreich wurde weil
ingo heidbrink an ein leben nach dem tod
glaubt wird es ihm irgendwann vielleicht
erzählen können im flugzeug hatte er mir
seine vorstellung vom paradies
geschildert vom jüngsten tag an dem
irgendeiner über ihn richten werde
das heißt das konkret dass
sie der sprung
mit bravour schaffen aber schaffen
ins paradies ja
vorerst kümmert sich heidbrink aber um
seinen selbst geschaffenen garten jeden
hier ist die verführung keine schlange
und die früchte sind zwar sündig aber
nicht verboten
[Musik]
nach der show sprach ich die sehr
bewegliche dame an denn ich wollte mit
ihr auf ein zimmer
richtig wohl war mir nicht als ich der
jungen frau in dieser aufmachung folgte
aber ich stellte mir vor dass es die
einzige möglichkeit war etwas mehr über
den alltag im bordell und über heidbrink
zu erfahren sie sagte sie heiße mirela
sein richtiger name nein nein wieso
nicht warum nicht
fantasiewelt hier dann kann ich mir auch
einen namen aus wie bist du auf diesen
job gekommen
was magst du gerne
wieso willst das aus früh ich möchte
zuerst wissen
je nach laune und fahre heute heute
momentan
etwas bequemer
das heißt das kuscheln genau wirkte hier
machst du so auch klappt wissen na klar
ich habe mal gehört das macht niemand
sonst wieso dann ja doch dazu gehört das
dazu
wie fühlst du dich dabei wenn du viel
geld mit einem kunden sex hast wie
sollen ich keinen spaß daran hast du
sprichst dabei spaß haben
das ist ein ganz normaler job noch spaß
da ja der mann hat spaß daran
kein problem damit nein und wie oft seid
ihr da auf diesem zettel als sonst
je nachdem
45 mal sehen mag ja zum beispiel
würde ist ja schon das ist mein vater
und mein bruder und auf der seite
dadurch meine mama und meine schwester
und was sagen sie dazu was sie dazu
sagen
wieder hat die sache jetzt immer wieder
beim anfang
darüber sprichst du nicht nein wie lange
bist du jeweils ziel die waren gestern
habe ich ja bereits
standard halbe stunde oder ich hab auch
gäste die film stunden mit mir
verbringen fünf stunden ja und das
kostet das kostet das wissen sie da wenn
die halbe stunde 140 us-dollar fiel der
chef alle lieben ihn du auch deshalb
weil er menschlich ist wirklich herr
geachtet auf uns ja aber jetzt verdient
sehr viel geld mit euch
mit ihm auch geht's euch gut dass wenn
es das nicht gäbe würden wir doch nicht
so viel verdienen ich blieb nur noch
kurz bei mir denn ich hatte noch fragen
an ihn geheilt bringt der saß im büro
und beobachtete das geschehen im club
über die monitore
[Musik]
doch habe
mein leben war nicht politisch trotzdem
rusko aber es geht schon mal
frei hat es okay es geht das orchester
vielleicht ritz warnt oder so die weiter
mutig und langsame reaktion ist oder so
hat schon probleme wochen in ihren
eigenen worten
ja so winzig roadster copen oder
dürfen es nicht anders sagen hansi bruch
kommen sie ja gesagt macht sie also ich
habe immer gewusst dass sie mit ihren
das interview
wie immer wir drehen sie das andere das
der damen also positiv
wir leben lerne ich bin im menschlichen
leben und das was ich gebe das romika
retter über das ist ganz normal
am selben tag besucht mir abends um acht
in liestal den neu eröffneten
klubhistorie
lifestyle klar
meine technik das ist was es ist
ich stehe und lifestyle
der klub heißt so weil die zimmer nach
historischen persönlichkeiten benannt
sind
das history funktioniert nach demselben
geschäftsmodell wie das globe in
schwärzenbach
[Musik]
herren und damen bezahlen einen eintritt
und können dann tun und lassen was sie
wollen
weit bringt verspricht sich von diesem
club viel für die zukunft gäste aus dem
süddeutschen raum sollen bald hier ein
und ausgehen
da läuft jetzt nicht so viel
wie so ja immer wenn ich
ein bisschen manche laufen
das war das also ist er einigermassen
das unternehmensziel das können sie mal
das laub nicht
einfach so war der
einfach dass der begriff
euro zugeführt wird und dann lage
ihre farben im jahr weiß genau was sie
machen wie es medien kind ja das ist
jetzt noch
diesen tagen hollywoods wie handelt man
hier sogar
entgegen wir respekt vor dem moment wo
es für bürger bfb
iso amazon ins auto
plötzlich irgendwie gruselig in vehlen
business tätig sind
aber ich mache das
[Musik]
so wie
es ist
dieser kenne ihn ja
das wurde ja einfach nicht wahr training
und balladen
[Musik]
das ingo heidbrink kein problem damit
habt liegt vielleicht an den 2,85
millionen franken einkommen die ehe im
letzten jahr privat versteuert hat eine
zahl die zeigt dass die geschäfte gut
laufen und das ist ziemlich viele männer
sind die seine klubs im letzten jahr
besucht haben mehr jedenfalls als dazu
stehen wollen
[Musik]